put Giannis and there is the handshake
there's the handshake Magnus Carlsen
just beats the Bell here he gets into
the playing hole a few seconds before
that clock ticks to zero and I must
admit I was having dinner with uh Magnus
every evening in Baku and he was just
talking about how tough it is especially
with choosing openings in classical
chess he was like oh I'm blocked here
I'm blocked there my opponent will force
to draw here my opponent will force to
draw there but it's kind of funny that
it looks like if you're playing Knight
F6 but then he Shadows everything and
Bishop F4 well that's a surprise that's
the London wow London system from kakash
I haven't seen him employ that for a
while
um I know it's in the Arsenal of the
repertoire of every top player these
days